Michael Scott might think he's the
world's best boss and a total ladies man
but really he's racist sexist and super
selfish and for every moment he does
something nice for one of his employees
there are a zillion more in which she's
incredibly cringy until settling down
with Holly flax Michael Scott's love
life involved a series of destructive
and disastrous relationships like the
time he broke every workplace rule by
dating Helene Beasley Pam's mom after
meeting at Jim and Pam's wedding Michael
and Helene hit it off much to Pam's hoar
eventually Jim and Pam are forced on a
double date with Michael and Helene when
Pam sees how happy her mom is with
Michael she warms up to the idea that
her boss might one day be part of the
family unfortunately the birthday party
is full of twists and turns and while
giving Helene a series of elaborate
gifts Michael finds out his girlfriend's
age and suddenly realizes she's a lot
older than him you're 58 years old huh
congratulations as a result he begins
looking for a way out of the
relationship right there in the
restaurant on her birthday Jim and Pam
watch mortified and shocked as Michael
lists all the reasons he should split up
with Helene such as the fact that he
wants to have kids visit Italy and
skydive all stuff he probably should
have discussed with his girlfriend
before professing his undying love to
her obviously the whole date is
incredibly painful to watch but at least
Michael gets his comeuppance when Pam
slaps him across the face Michael Scott
and Ryan Howard have always had a weird
relationship Michael wants to be Ryan's
mentor his best friend and occasionally
his lover
unfortunately this obsessive friendship
only goes one way so Ryan manipulates
his boss case in point when Ryan brings
Michael to his business school so he can
do a Q&A Michael can't wait to impart
his wisdom to the next generation sadly
it's all a setup Ryan has no respect for
his manager or the paper business and he
knows the class will eat Michael alive
of course Michael does a pretty good job
of sabotaging himself by walking into
the classroom accompanied by his own
theme song Plus Michael is a big
believer in visual aids and one of his
teaching methods involves hitting a
student in the head with
candy bar the most awkward moment comes
in Michael explains the basics of
business to these MBA students lecturing
that the more stickers you sell the more
profit fancy word for money you have to
buy Playstations and beanie babies
but once the students start asking
questions it becomes painfully obvious
that Michael is in way over his head
the final twist of the cringing knife
comes when he discovers that Ryan has
betrayed him it's a humiliating
experience but at least Michael gets the
last laugh by forcing Ryan to work
alongside his least favorite person in
the office his own girlfriend Kelly
Kapoor Michael Scott thinks he's a
natural-born leader but he's also
incredibly insecure so whenever an
authority figure suddenly shows up
Michael gets super competitive that's
definitely the case in season two when
Michael takes his employees on a booze
cruise even before the ship set sail
Michael refuses to admit the fact that
the captain of the boat outranks the
manager of the office in fairness
Captain Jack is a bit of a jerk himself
but it's his ship and whenever Jack
tries to make an announcement or get a
party game going there's Michael
stealing the mic and trying to spark a
one-man mutiny but things get really bad
when Jack kicks off the dance contest as
Michael is giving a speech on leadership
skills ever the master of improv Michael
decides to go with the flow by taking
over the dance floor and giving everyone
a motivational dance lesson with
everybody staring in horror Michael
pulls out all of his best moves he skips
and shakes he's high-stepping and
knee-slapping even throws in the worm
for good measure Phyllis is so ashamed
that she looks away as other spectators
bite their lips to keep from laughing
but Michael is completely oblivious as
far as he's concerned he's the real
captain of the ship
the best regional manager and the king
of the dance floor give Michael Scott a
microphone and you're guaranteed to
regret it that's a lesson we all learned
the hard way in the season two premiere
when Michael hosts the dundies an annual
awards show of Michael's own making the
dundies show is supposed to reward the
office for their hard work instead it's
an opportunity for Michael to make every
and squirm in their seats it all starts
with a horrible hip-hop number complete
with cue card mishaps and tech issues
things get racial when Michael hands
Kelly the spicy curry award and assumes
the white woman with Stanley isn't his
wife both Phyllis and Angela win
trophies that highlight parts of the
body best left unmentioned at work
events and ryan realizes Michaels true
feelings for him when he's given the
hottest in the office award
Pam describes the horror of the dundies
perfectly when she compares it to a car
crash one that's so bad you've got to
stare at it because your boss is making
you in Michael Scott's defense he isn't
always a bad guy often times he means
well and in certain rare moments he can
be pretty cool for example he's on his
best behavior in season six when the
office is hanging out during happy hour
in fact when he meets Pam's friend Julie
he actually treats her like a real human
being he's funny
polite and charming and the two really
hit it off until Michael learns that Pam
brought Julie along in hopes of setting
them up once Michael realizes he's on a
date he morphs into one of his most
obnoxious characters date Mike date Mike
nice and made me wearing a backwards
Kangol hat and armed with tips from
reality TV date Mike struts around the
bar with his chest hair exposed tries
tying a cherry stem with his tongue only
to choke on it and spins his pool cue
like he's some sort of slick hustler a
move that majorly backfires when he
sends drinks flying across the room the
worst part comes when date might climbs
up on the pool table and starts dancing
his way across the felt he even picks a
fight with a bar owner before a bouncer
shows up once date Mike is distracted
Julie heads for the hills unimpressed by
Michael's particular brand of charm from
the moment he puts that hat on until
he's playing his pool cue like an
electric guitar we're all desperately
hoping that date Mike would just
disappear holidays are always
interesting around the Scranton office
sometimes there's a civil war brewing
and the party planning committee and
occasionally a drunken Meredith will set
herself on fire it's hard to get through
the holidays without some sort of
hilarious drama but during season three
things are especially
dad for Michael Scott he's just broken
up with his girlfriend Carol so he
decides to find a rebound accompanied by
his entourage of Andy Dwight and a
reluctant Jim Michael lets loose at the
restaurant in both he and Andy managed
to pick up two waitresses a few scenes
later the duo returns to the office
Christmas party with their dates but
Michael ends up confusing the two Asian
women and can't remember which one is
his date after he finally figures out
which waitress he brought to the party
we're treated to one of the most
hysterical and humiliating Michael Scott
moments he brings his date in for a big
hug and then marks her arm with a magic
marker so that he won't ever get the two
women confused again it's a new low for
Michael Scott and as always the regional
manager has an unacceptable excuse
claiming that all waitresses look alike
for all his flaws Michael Scott somehow
runs the most successful office in
Dunder Mifflin so when the Stamford
branch shuts down six employees are sent
over to Scranton but thanks to Michael's
unique personality and a whole lot of
office drama the folks from Stamford
abandon ship and the first to go is poor
Tony we don't know Tony all that well
before he flees but he seems like a
perfectly nice person however Michael
decides to make Tony's weight into a big
issue the same way he focuses on all of
his employees quirks or insecurities for
comedy value hoping to welcome the new
employees to his branch Michael
encourages them all to climb on top of a
table so they can be admired by everyone
else of course Tony is too heavy to get
up there
but despite pleading with Michael to
skip this ridiculous ritual the boss
insists telling Tony use the momentum of
your lower half to hoist yourself up
obviously Tony is frustrated and
humiliated but things reach unbearable
levels when Michael and Dwight grabbed
Tony's legs and tried to shove him up
onto the table it's all too much
and Tony quits right then and there
telling Michael that his management
style isn't so great after all
needless to say Michael doesn't take
this very well and fires his new
employee it's impossible not to feel bad
for Tony after he's had to deal with
Michaels frankly offensive wait jabs
Michael Scott always has to be the
center of attention even at someone
else's wedding
so when bride-to-be Phyllis asks Michael
to push her father down the aisle in a
wheelchair the boss sees it as his time
to shine however about halfway to the
altar the old guy decides to get up and
walk it's a miraculous moment and while
everyone in the church is elated
Michael is left in the lurch been pretty
angry about it Michael
angrily tells the cameraman me walking
Phyllis down the aisle was supposed to
be the highlight of the way just like a
toddler Michael throws a tantrum by
noisily dragging the wheelchair down the
aisle
he then squeezes himself between the
groomsmen determined to be an important
part of the ceremony and that's when
Michael starts calculating how he can
steal the show right after Phyllis says
I do
Michael jumps out and loudly announces
the two as a couple
the trouble is bob hasn't said I do yet
and Michael is forced to slink back in
line
then during the wedding speeches Michael
steals the mic and gives an impromptu
and unwelcome wedding speech complete
with quotes from The Princess Bride
celebrity couple names and off-color
jokes about poor Phyllis sure Michael
accidentally redeems himself before the
night is over but all these years later
this probably remains the cringy
aesthetic in TV history
let's give Michael Scott some credit for
the nice things he's done he was a
father figure to Aaron he played
paintball with Dwight he showed up at
Pam's Art Show and bought one of her
paintings but all of these wonderful
things are canceled out by what happened
in the show's sixth season during the
offices most painfully cringy episode
Scott's
Tots years ago Michael Scott fell in
love with a group of low-income
elementary students figuring he'd be a
millionaire by the time the kids were
ready to graduate Michael promised he'd
pay their college tuition but when it
comes time to shell out Michael is still
just a middling regional manager who
once tried to hop on a train because his
finances got so bad so when he's forced
to visit the school to meet the now
grown-up kids
adorably known as Scott's tots the
tension is absolutely unbearable I want
people to be afraid of how much they
love me when Michael shows up at the
school the kids absolutely adore him
they give speeches thanking him for
changing their lives and they even put
on a song and dance number to show him
their gratitude
by the time they're done performing a
guilty and terrified Michael gets up in
front of the class and reveals he can't
pay for anything
instead he bought them all laptop
batteries to make up for his major
mistake needless to say this does not go
over well with Scott Stotts Michael
Scott might have good intentions but the
size of his heart doesn't match the size
of his brain check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite TV shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]